good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 42:52 object
class Keter special containment
procedures SCP 42:52 a is held in an
airtight windowless room structurally
disconnected from sight 96 the room
filters into a 200,000 liter drum buried
below the site on the first of every
month SCP 4252 s activation phrase as
found on SCP 4250 to be should be
vocalized upon the manifestation of SCP
4252 all personnel present must bow
refer to it as Lord jettisoned and each
recite one of the complimentary phrases
provided below and the phrases are as
follows you are so wise Lord jettison
you are so brave
Lord jettisoned you are so kind
Lord jettisoned you are so small
Lord jettisoned you are so pure Lord
jettison Lord jettisoned you spoil us
with your grace your smallness is
immensely large oujet ascent the mighty
game I am lucky to be in your presence
Lord jettison
long live Lord jettisoned
once SCP 4252 gives the command all
personnel are to avert their eyes and
all cameras are to be temporarily
disabled for the duration of 30 seconds
at which point cameras are to be
re-enabled and all activities are to
resume as usual description SCP 4252 a
refers to a collection of four objects
hereby referred to as SCP 4252 a one
forty to fifty two eight two forty to
fifty two a three and forty to fifty to
a four all of which are filled with
baked beans SCP 4252 a one is a clock
identical to a burn our products brand
quartz wall clock SCP 42:52 a two is a
brown leather briefcase of unknown make
SCP 42:52 a three is a cardboard coffee
cup sporting the Starbucks coffee
company logo SCP 42:52 a 4 is a 2015
toyota highlander prior to incident 1
all four objects have the same anomalous
properties but following the event SCP
42:52 a 1 has been neutralized
SCP 4252 a-two a-three and a-four
infinitely produced baked beans via
unknown methods probing the interiors
has found no evidence of any physical
passage through which the baked beans
enter indicating that they manifest
directly within the object there is no
known way to stop the beans from being
produced without the use of SCP 42:52
the beans would breach containment in
less than three months SCP 42:52 is a
humanoid entity no more than half a
metre tall it wears a long silk robe
covered in jewels and the crown made of
bronze with a single ruby ovoid in the
center
SCB 42:52 was able to manifest and be
manifest however prior to incident a1 it
was only ever observed to appear when a
specific phrase found on SCP 4252 B was
spoken SCP 42:52 B is a fabric ribbon of
unknown origin
written across the face in gold sequins
is the following phrase Jefferson the
mighty game please bless our presence
with your own consume our bubbling Venus
pile from atop pure sparkling throw once
every month when the phrase is spoken
out loud SCP 4252 will manifest nearby
and request all those around it to bow
and shower it with compliments it will
become increasingly agitated if these
needs are not met swiftly and has
threatened to D manifest following
further non-compliance once SCP 42:52 is
satisfied it will locate SCP 4252 8 and
proceed to consume all of the baked
beans that have been produced
however personnel attempting to monitor
this either through direct observation
or via camera recording are met with a
request by SCP 42:52 to stop watching it
as it can't do it when people are
looking because of this no visual
evidence exists of SCP 4252 s removal of
the baked beans but audio recordings
indicate the sounds of a viscous
substance being violently disturbed when
all the beans are removed SCP 42:52 will
D manifest leaving with a forceful belch
the loudest of which as measured and
well over 120 decibels attempting to
summon SCP 42:52 again by means of its
activation phrase are met with a dial
tone and a voice recording of SCP 42:52
indicating that it is not ready yet
me like a month and I'll get back to you
further attempts result in a dial tone
incident oh one
this is a transcript of video log 42 50
to 120 202 April 6th 2019 a humanoid
figure similar in size to SCP 4252 but
with a tall pointed hat and a blue rope
manifests in SCP 4252 phase containment
room
it looks frantically around before
removing a long red wand from a pocket
in its robe it points the object an SCP
4250 to a one and a bolt of green light
shoots out of it hitting SCP 42 50 to a
120 202 April 6th 2019 SCP 4252
manifests and tackles the figure they
wrestle for 30 seconds at which point
the intruder grabs a cp-40 252 s arm and
breaks it as cp-40 252 screams kicks the
figures head and continues to do so
until it stops moving SCP 42 52 steps
away to breathe then collapses onto the
ground in front of the figures body and
begins to sob heavily 2204 April 6th
2019 as CP 42:52 collects itself and
leans over the body of the figure it
gingerly closes the body's eyes whispers
something inaudible grabs the corpse and
D manifests note following this incident
SCP 42:52 a1 remains in a neutralized
State SCP 42:52 continues to manifest as
usual but where its right arm was
previously there is now a mechanical
replacement limp due to the self
manifestation of SCP 42:52 it has been
reclassified as Keter
SCP 4252 the king of baked beans don't
ask me why but SCP 42:52 reminds me of
those little creatures from mario with
with the magic wands also I'd like to
give special thank you to dr. Henry
Rosen he's in charge of researching
containment at site 96 for providing me
with this information so quickly so
thank you dr. Rosen but I think that
about does it for today thank you for
listening if indeed you still are and
you are all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabah Chris all hens I'd paw blue ice
917 Kareem el ash mooing Justin day
Thomas Morin Curie kuma white crew and
jayvo Jack crystal spice my archive
curator Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy King
modding and the Wonder thank you all so
much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you